QUESTION: So what I really want to take from your
research is an idea that this
pro-democracy nationalism inoculates
against the anti-democracy
nationalism. But when I think of the
riots in Gujarat, which happened 20 years
after independence, and five years before the time period you're talking
about, and the rise of the BJP today, I
can't take away that message. So
what is the message that I can
take away about the difference and the
interplay of these two types of
nationalisms? MAYA TUDOR: Yeah, it's a great question.
MARGARET LEVI:  Much better said than what I was
trying to get at. TUDOR: Right, so I guess what I
would say is that the word "inoculates" is
far too strong. All the explanations that
political scientists have for when
democracy does or doesn't come about,
they're all probabilistic explanations.
They're not—nothing, not a super
diverse ethnic group, a super high level
of economic development,
Nothing is absolutely sufficient to become a
democracy. So the claim that I'm making
is that, all else being equal, and of
course, nothing else is ever equal, right?
Because countries are very particular
space-and-time
-specific creations, but that all else
being equal, a relatively flat and open
porous conception of what it means to be
a member of that nation is a resource
for democracy because of subsequent
moments of political crisis, when you
have political entrepreneurs pushing to
get to power. If there is by
contrast a narrative of nation that
specifically sets aside a
group as not being core to defining the
nation, that in moments of crisis, that
particular group can be more easily
targeted by politicians in power. And
that's what you see happening with
Muslims, the Rohingya in Myanmar,
it's what you see today happening
in India, and what you saw when Modi was
the Chief Minister of Gujarat, which is
when the riots that you mentioned
happened. He's very much been pushing a
Hindu nationalist vision. And it's not a
coincidence that's exactly where you saw
the riots happening in India, because
it's where the chief politician in power
was pushing a majoritarian view of what
it meant to be a citizen of that nation.
So to go back to your question, what do I
take away from this talk? It's not that
anything inoculates democracy.
Democracy is only as strong as our
belief in it and our willingness to
essentially make sacrifices on behalf of
a particular way of organizing and
sharing power. But what I can say is that
in addition to all those structural
factors which do make democracy a little
bit more likely. So if you're a little
bit wealthier, a little bit more likely.
If you don't have oil and gas as a
major part of your export, democracy is a
little more likely. And what I want to
add to the conversation is when you have
a nationalism that's relatively
egalitarian, it makes democracy a little
more likely for the reasons I mentioned.
LEVI: Except that in all these cases you have both kinds of nationalism pervading.
TUDOR: Right. So I think that's another...so just briefly, I think that
that was a question I was sure
I was gonna get. "You know, when
you're talking about one nationalism, but
there are lots of kinds of nationalisms."
And I think that's absolutely true.
Founding moments provide particularly
powerful narratives of what the nation
is, but of course those narratives are
contested and changing over time. But they're often surprisingly
durable. And what you see happening
in India right now is a sustained
attempt to change what the national
identity is, and to the extent that it
endures, it's in power, it begins to change
national curriculums, which, you know,
is exactly what we're seeing, that will
become a resource for essentially
promoting one form of democratic
breakdown just when those civil and
political liberties are systematically
denied to the out groups.